i've i've really tried to do a
combination of it
accepting the hands that have been dealt
and trying to work on my own stuff you
know
the first evil dead movie will always be
what it is
it's a crude low budget sometimes
shocking
horror movie but the thing that i will
always take away from that
is the four years that it took to make
it and to get the money
and to raise it and to shoot some and
then six months later shoot some more
and six months later shoot some more
and get your father to hawk property
so that you can get money to blow it up
from 16 millimeter to the 35.
i caught my father he had just gotten
divorced from my mother
and was sitting on the back porch
staring staring off into the woods
behind our house and i go dead
uh we gotta we we're not gonna get this
movie into theaters unless it gets to 35
millimeter
that's about a 50 000 uh
operation can i
can we use the property it was in
northern michigan can we use that can i
can i go and get a loan against that to
do it he goes
yeah yeah i don't care just like didn't
care oh but it was
because my dad had been destroyed and
and the prodigal son
i got him right when i when i knew i
could i could get him to say yes because
he didn't care he
he was so despondent we go up to the mid
michigan bank
in gladwin michigan and have a meeting
with the guy
at the mid michigan bank and go we like
to get
a loan for 50 000 to blow up a motion
picture and the guy didn't know what a
blow up you know
it's a lab process of course but he
didn't know he goes guys
you can blow up whatever you want but if
you don't pay it back we're taking the
property do you understand how this
works he said that just like that we got
it
oh yeah he didn't want to hear all the
technical he loans to farmers you
know he doesn't loan to filmmakers
right fortunately we paid it back but
that's what sticks out to me is
i'll always be proud of my homies sam
raymond rob chappert
we did the craziest crap to get this
thing done to pull it off detroit you
don't make movies in detroit
1979 and inflation was horrible and the
interest rates were you know 20 20
some stupid amount it was a bad
environment for investors you know and
so
i didn't even i was so you know to me
when i could go
to my local cinema and watch evil dead
on the screen at a matinee with 20
people in the theater
i didn't care it's where i saw the
poseidon adventure
oh it doesn't matter ever we made it on
the screen
and that was way early in the process we
hadn't even made any money yet and i'm
like we did it how much did your dad
make on that 50.
oh he did good every time he got a check
his quote was
oh god it's like finding it in the
street
you know like he just he just tripped
over it in the street
and my mom made my parents divorced and
they split
their portions of what they owned of the
movie and i got a check and every time i
get a check
i knew that my mom would get a check and
i'd call her up and go mom
you get your checks she goes yeah i go
what are you gonna do with it she goes
i'm getting all new anderson windows
that was her favorite brand i love
window
and they say you know bam she's got the
whole house and beautiful double pane
anderson windows she lived in michigan
how many call her up in the
in the dead ass i bought ten of them
they're like a thousand bucks each you
know
and i call her up you know dead of
winter ma
how you doing ma she goes i'm feeling
pretty toasty with those anderson
windows
my god that's what evil dead means to me
that my parents got
my dad could find money in the street
and my mom could buy anderson windows
you